hello everybody welcome to another video
i am chris d'elia on code Tech and
tutorials nerd version of Chris D'Elia
alright I'm going to show you today a
it's an example use regex
and c++ something I did recently just
for like a project sort of a side
project just assists so I thought maybe
this would make a good video and it's a
little hard to figure out at first how
to properly do regex so I'm just gonna
go through my intention my program its
use case and how I did it and hopefully
that'll help some of you out there that
are trying to get an understanding regex
and how it can be potentially useful my
case here is it relates to Dungeons and
Dragons and the spells so basically long
story short a little setup here I was
trying to find a nice solid list of all
the spells with all the details and a
format that I could parse and I found
one I found a JSON format somewhere on
github I think I kind of treated where I
found it but it had some problems a lot
of the data was incorrect and it wasn't
really fully usable for what I wanted to
do because I didn't really want to have
a bunch of incorrect data so I decided
okay I'll parse through it correct all
the stuff that he's corrected and redo
it on my own and initially I started
typing everything out manually copying
and pasting stuff over and it was taking
forever forever
so what I did is I felt I just like made
a spell parser thing that's what I
called it and I'm going to show you what
it does and how it uses it how it goes
through this might be a little scattered
I don't really plan this out thoroughly
so that's why I'm gonna launch Visual
Studio code on this folder just to show
you all my files
alright here we go so this is this is
what we got oh I'll take it from the top
here
I started out with a main which is this
spell parser and made a couple global
burial variables now now everything
isn't necessarily up to standards here I
kind of just did it to get it working I
didn't really I skipped a few of my
normal steps of like optimizing things
and stuff because I was like I don't
care I just wanted to work and then I'm
done so that's that's what I was going
for here so I'll take it from the top
and just walk through this I think that
might be the best way to explain it but
it might also be important to show you
where I was really starting from before
the code I was looking at this file I
was looking at this data to parse
through so this is JSON format I know
you can there's a library for C++ hang
it's called JSON they can use to also
handle JSON data and maybe that would be
better for some cases but after looking
through it I decided to just build my
own both for experience and getting more
used to regex and just make sure I'm
doing it exactly how I want so those
were my reasons for using regex to be
perfectly honest it might make more
sense to use a JSON parser library
rather than build your own but I really
just wanted to build my own is what it
came down to honestly it's I get pretty
excited about coding okay I'm gonna move
this over here that way my face is not
blocking half the code so this is just
all the spells here's one here's a spell
as you can see it's a sucess it's slash
it's for these classes and here's one of
the data problems right off the bat
so as Rogan fighter are the classes that
use it if you look on the players
handbook and stuff these are it doesn't
list rogen fighters the casters so I
wanted to strip all this wrong data out
of here now that's not to say that
rogues and wizards can never cast this
spell because they can there are are
types of rogues and wizards as you level
up where you can get these spells but by
default they're not listed as casters of
the spell and I wanted to stick to how
the books have it so I wanted that was
part of
correcting all this data was to make the
classes correct and there's the
components are listed an array the
classes were listed an array
there was duration level material range
ritual con school the source where it
came from the text the description of
the spell and the casting time so I
wanted to pull all this data end and
redo it in my new format that I like
better and could work with better and it
just goes through every spell a lot of
this is wrong though often they get the
material wrong often they get two
components wrong option they get to
classes wrong there was just a lot of
problems going through this data I
couldn't parse it in verbatim or use it
just as it was so so then I was like
alright I'm gonna do it do it all myself
so I did a bunch of them I typed it out
a bunch of them I copied pasted over
manually checked I mean took forever
spent so many hours on this and then one
day I was just like you know I'm just
gonna build something to finish this out
so that's that's where this comes in and
all right so that's what I was working
with this is what I would to parse in
and I guess I will show you also what I
was going for like what it should look
like once I could parse it in and bring
it into my style so I was I was going
into format it like this put in a one
giant array called ice all spells one
giant array and in my way it looks like
this I just have it one big piece of
data with name class level all this
stuff as you can see most of these are
strings like I turned instead of class
as being an array it's just strings was
comma separator that's one of the things
that would make it easier for me to
parse it in or to work with it I wanted
it in a string here so there was stuff
like that just improvements this is an
integer this is a ritual was a bool
variable another integer here everything
else is a string components no longer an
array it's just
string material they had no occasionally
here I didn't want it to ever be Noll
just because of how I was using it I
wanted to just say none so it was
another correction all right so that
that's was the intention to just
beautify it make it better and these are
this is from a repo called D&D 5e
perfect spells so all these all the new
corrected data is up on github anyone
wants that this format of all the spells
it's out there I've already built it and
now I'm going you back and showing how
I'll probably I'll put those links in
the description too and I will make this
code public for the spell parser as well
as of this recording it's private but
that was just why I was building it okay
so let's get right into it now of how I
want it okay so I want to I want to
iterate through this text grab each one
and push it on to vector basically so I
wanted a model of all the classes which
is here yeah okay where's age spell
model dot H okay
so here's here's the model of all the
classes we have all these things so
anytime we parse out a new spell we want
to grab all these things and as part of
the model I went ahead and and built the
function to find each of these required
I hope this makes sense and I got our
little reset model because I'm just
using the same model over and over and
the way I signed it it seemed to I
thought it would be a more memory
efficient this way but honestly it
doesn't matter
and also just each model knows how to
find parts to set it stuff it just
seemed kind of cool so that's how I did
my mom alright back to the spell parser
let's walk through this so I did all my
includes did those in a separate file
just to keep it a little cleaner there
they all are yeah I do use that stream
in the end so we'll leave that there
all right so include almost stuff using
namespace standard that's pretty
standard stuff just
you know type standard : : all the time
all right so there's here's my big
vector of final spells that I want as I
want to as I parse through the file or
build up this vector every time I finish
out a spell I'm gonna push it on here
reset the model and start a new one
push it on when it's done so at the end
I'll have a bunch have a string that I
use over and over that's just pulling in
the data to search for holding that and
here's each spell spell iteration
variable is what that means so anytime I
just populate this push it on to the
vector clear it populate again pushing
on the vector so that's that's kind of
the cycle here and now we get to the
main yeah there's only three pieces of
data I'm holding on to the rest is uh
you'll see you'll see again let's see
chris d'elia
nerd version of crystal II it will
explain all right int main yeah I'm not
using the arc CoV I don't care
okay I'm keeping track of steps so this
is how I'm just how I decided to do it I
decided to go through a switch statement
depending on which step it's on it
determines what it's trying to find so
first we find the name find a class find
the component and so on we basically
just go through the whole thing and find
it piece by piece
as we need to so it starts at step zero
lining the name and we want to keep
track of whether the search was
successful or not
every time we try to find one reason
being let me scroll down a little bit is
if it was successful we go to the next
step and we reset the success if it
wasn't we stay on this same step and get
the next line hoping that it will
contain it reason being is occasionally
we'll get a line that's just a bracket
and we want to skip over those and go to
the next line if that's the case or we
get something like this where we don't
need that data we're looking for the
rest of the beat
so there's in a cave there's occasions
where it's unsuccessful and we want this
success variable to handle that so it
repeats the case if it needs to
and as you will see eventually here at
the end of this video I will run it in
and show you that it works all right so
I have have some just notifications for
the user just to tell you whether it
worked or not
in the end I could get rid of these but
they were very handy while building so I
can tell if it was successful or not on
actual step and correct as needed
okay so goes under the first step tells
the user what it's doing this is really
just for my debugging purposes while
building these don't need to be here
tells you what it's searching through
and then tells you whether it finds it
or not spell name blah blah if it finds
it so it's only a success if not it goes
next line it will tell you a still step
zero now look through this data and so
this might be better said like this
looking through done oh yeah same thing
it was this day so this is pretty
standard C++ stuff here right here using
a switch statement using a wild get line
so eventually this get line will fail
and that's when it finally exits the
loop and that's going to be the very end
of the file so that's that's the point
of that now where am I getting this data
to search so I'm getting introduced
through CN so when I run this I want to
be sure to use a pipe of the file I mean
I could also do a nice dream or an if
stream and open it that way but in my
case I chose to just pipe in one so when
I run it I'm doing command line I don't
know if this is clear to you but this is
the make file for for the whole thing
it's not intended to be super perfect
it's just kind of good enough to work so
usually I was just doing make test one
or make test two every time I was
running it to see if how it was doing
and see how I was coming along on the
process as you can see make test one it
it builds builds the main thing and then
it just runs it so if I did updates it
would just build it and then run
test case right away so it's intended to
be ran with you know the final target
name dot /a sparser and sparser and then
pipe in the data that way see and picks
it up was a guest line every time that's
how it's intended to be ran okay so
we'll go back here here we go
so it just does that over and over just
keeps getting the next line keeps trying
to handle the data goes to the next
steps are successful and as you can see
it just it just does everything here it
just does all the all the fields so I
think this is probably pretty obvious
now I'm not going to go through each of
these individually on this particular
main but I will say that once it gets to
the end once case the last case is
successful case 12 you hit the default
case because it's 13 and it resets
everything it says okay now we'll go
back to step 0 we're gonna push back the
spell we filled up onto that vector so
we start building up that vector every
time here we go and we go ahead and
reset the model should I'll show you
here reset model basically just resets
all the variables and then it tells the
user their spells complete a spells
complete so you'll see this a bunch of
times as it goes through it and yeah
it'll just start back at case 0 start
and if it's at the end of the file it'll
exit the wire loop next program so what
happens when it doesn't fully extrema
exits the while loop here's the end of
the while loop right here
and wild ok so so you get to the end of
the file you've been building up spells
and here's what it does at the very very
end I didn't build this too after I
built all the regex stuff will show you
the regex stuff in just a second tells
you how many spells it ended up grabbing
and it does that by just looking at that
spells grab vector and doing a size on
it so you can see how big it is so
that's how many spells a gret and then
I put this in here just to have an
example of what I was going for on the
output and I made a little output
there's other ways to do this but
basically I just created an out stream
of a file called alt text text and did
the required C out or well in this case
alt stream which is an upstream it just
pushes it to the file I had to do a
special thing for the ritual because
they come in as a zero or one and I
wanted them as true or false because
those work very nicely and JSON you want
a true or false so I went ahead and I
said oh yeah that's why I didn't correct
the formatting because it messes up my
messes up this I wanted this to stay the
same so I could do just format this all
right
so basically I just do a for loop on all
the spells grabbed / spell and we just
make sure this is open we see what the
ritual was whether it's true or false if
it's true we call this string true
otherwise it's all false that's used
later down here that way we're not
putting out a 0 or 1 in the spot we want
an actual true or false JSON likes that
kind of stuff otherwise it's gonna think
it's an integer we want we want it to be
a true or false on a string just the
actual word truevolt so I had to make
that little correction that's what
that's what this here's about so there
it is we just output each little section
of the JSON and I had to do some escape
characters too to put in the quotations
new line at the end of them you probably
I probably don't need to explain this in
too much detail if you're confused by it
at all
why don't leave a comment or something I
guess but then when it's all done it
flushes the out stream and then closes
it so basically this out text should be
a giant
the decently formatted JSON it might
need a few Corrections but comes out
pretty well of all the data I basically
just need to encapsulate it and they all
spells a Rea thing I've shown you
earlier because it comes out from here
to here like that's what it outputs each
little spell it outputs is that so one
then it does the next one and actually
next one the only thing I need to do is
put them inside of this just pretty easy
compared to typing out all this manually
this is five thousand over five thousand
lines of spells so I was doing it
manually for awhile just never again
I'll just rather build something like
this all right so how my parson needs
how am i grabbing these individually
hapless the regex look like finally
finally we're to the step alright so
I'll show ya it's it's part of the spell
model and it's just all this class so I
just basically build up this class I
build all these finds to custom make
sure they found things correctly it was
a little tricky you're right it really
was so I'm doing an extern of the spell
spell iteration bar this is just the
same data as this here that way I can
just populate stuff right to it so
that's that's global and that makes it
easy for me to just push stuff on to or
change it but I'm gonna do extra special
things like passing it to each I don't
want to have to pass it to each of these
calls so that's why I made it global
instead not necessarily the best coding
practice I mean sometimes it's fine
somehow would you want to do that but I
was just doing it to save my own time
honestly and you know not have to retype
the same thing over and over so let's go
through a couple of these defined and
set name this is the first one that
calls case 0 it looks at the string you
passed in I did it as a constant by
reference because this data you're
searching through will never change you
shouldn't be editing it so it's safe to
do it that way
but the things I do on each of these
call
I be sure to make a regex pattern that
should grab the name but doesn't grab
let me find this okay but doesn't glad
grab anything else I just want to I just
want to grab acid splash oh we're on the
second one I just want to grab the word
aid or alarm now one thing I can count
on is that these go on order in order so
that's that's one way I built this is
considering that it was passed to you in
order like you could you're gonna get
this name this and then this it's not
gonna be jumbled at all so I made it a
little easier to stream through it or
iterate through it rather okay so just
looks for this pattern this pattern is
looks for a capital letter because the
name of spells are capital and then it
looks for any of these characters which
is a through Z through Z a space or an
apostrophe because some spells have a
little ' like tensors floating disk for
example so that was the regex pattern
I'm looking for on the name and s
matches our smashes that's a it's a part
of the regex matches is an array of
strings as is really all this so and
then you do a regex search which returns
a bool if it's successful so you can
throw it in an if so I'm gonna search
through whatever pattern alright search
search this is the this is the string
I'm passing into search through looking
for this pattern if I find anything it
goes on the matches array and here we go
so if it comes back successful just
gonna go ahead and call the name the
first one and return true that way when
it returns true over here
called success true tells you the next
thing ends up going the next step of
finding classes next so it kind of just
repeats this for each one so next we're
looking for classes class some of these
were more complicated than others
classes was kind of hard because I'm
looking at a case of they're on
different lines and some of them I don't
want to I could never want rogue
never want fighter and definitely don't
want this or the brackets or anything
like that so I had to sign it in that
way so I made my little pattern here
classes always starts with a capital
letter so we got we got that and then
it's always more letters this could
probably actually be lowercase like so
and it would work fine but some reason I
have it
considering capitals more capitals too
so that's that's a pretty basic pattern
there of course same thing with the
matches and we do the same type of
search so these are gonna be very
similar over and over here and my dog is
looking at me and wine in for some
reason
what's up doggie nothing okay she was
just out don't worry don't worry Chris
D'Elia takes care of his animals and
let's see okay so if we find something
we want to see you want to compare it to
a rogue and compared to fighter if it
ends up being either of those as you
know the compare if it equals zero means
it's an exact match so then it's up
matching rogue or fighter we say no we
return false so it basically just goes
to the next line as per this this here
and not going to the next step is a
stays on the same step goes on X while
loop and finds the next one but we want
to say if it gets passed this doesn't
return false it'll keep going you don't
say all right if it's length is greater
than or equal to two three that was just
a way of making sure didn't grab him
some other random thing it gets past
this in general it's probably a legal
case but I put at least something in
there to do a little bit of a guard oh
wait wait wait
yeah yeah okay so it's greater than or
equal to three it's already pushed
something on to this like because as I
showed I want them as a comma-separated
string rather than an array so if
there's already something on it is
basically all this is check
and it appends a comma space and then
adds the next class and returns false
because hey maybe there's more as you
can see there on all in separate lines
by default okay yeah let's see where
here we go
and if it's smaller than this size it's
for the first one so we don't need a
common space we just put that on there
that's the first one with an equals
notice these are plus equals to append
to the string rather than overwrite it
this one note is would be only the first
case the very first time it just makes
it that and then if there's more it
starts appending this stuff to it and
then if it gets past all of this like if
it no longer matches anything it hits
this case down here we want to check and
make sure that there's at least
something in it so I just did a size
greater than two just to have some kind
of guard make sure it's not a blank
string we return true when that ended up
being good enough to do all the cases
and if it ends up getting past this then
it's another false so I always have
return false and in case it didn't work
and it needs to go to the next next step
or if it needs to stay on the same step
and try again
so this ended up working for for finding
all these cases of appending these
classes alright let's look at components
I don't know if I should do all these I
guess it won't hurt to do all these but
for sake of time I think I'm just gonna
do a couple more so we're looking at
components components is these single
character strings of s and V is how they
had it so I had to look at those cases
and consider those but I want the fools
spelled out word I don't want an S snv's
I wanted my JSON to have the full word
so what I did is I'm just matching a
capital letter and when we get a match
I'm doing once again making sure if the
string exists if the string is not blank
or yet because we want to start
appending if it is
but if it's a blank string the first one
doesn't need the comma space it's just
you know the first word as you can see
I'm comparing the match to an S that
matches then we're gonna call you know
or pending somatic it's an M we're gonna
pin to material it's a V we're gonna pin
ball and that's it's very similar to the
way the class is due because we need to
I get the first one actually these
should be equals but I guess it doesn't
matter because the strings gonna be
blank anyways and after the first one we
want to start a pending after a comma
space and the same thing as long as
there's something there it's gonna
return true at the very end if it
stopped hitting cases where it's finding
stuff after finding some stuff all right
let's look at duration duration was a
little tricky because sometimes starts
with a capital letter sometimes it
starts with a number like it could be
eight hours it could be 1 minute it
could be what else for the cases let's
see this it could be instantaneous the
capital I there's an 8 hours so we
didn't to make sure it found all these
but didn't find didn't grab the word
duration we don't want to grab the word
duration and this one's concentration up
to one hour and it has a comma in there
that we would need to grab so this one
was definitely a little tricky this one
took me a little more time than some of
the others to get the regex right is it
so this is kind of weird it's probably
needs a few Corrections and I've been
iteratively making this a little better
but as of right now it runs good enough
to at least get everything accurately
even if some stuff seems odd now here's
one of the odd things that could be
corrected to make it a little a little
better because as you can see it has to
start with a capital A a capital A
through Z or a number so it's never
gonna be the word duration but for some
reason I'm still checking for the word
duration and making sure it's not that I
think that was just one way I was
building earlier and didn't correct it
so that's gonna be false all the time
anyway we can just give
and say okay if it finds something
Isis appendant return true if it doesn't
find something turned false as you'd see
okay so starts with this and it's
followed by any of these numbers
characters of comma spaces that seem to
handle it so this worked pretty well and
then we want to find level now level is
just a number you know a zero through
nine so euro fork and trips level nine
max so that's all we're looking for here
on this line of a level now this was see
what I have to turn this into a string
is one of the things I had to do here
just to be able to push it to was it
pushing it to oh just for the case of
matching okay because when we do this
Rezac search when we get it when we get
a match it it saves the match as a
string so it's just like a single
character that's a number and a string
but we want it as an integer so that's
why I had to go through all this
nonsense of care are you gonna make it a
string that's just for test an enum
string making sure this here make sure
that it's only numbers and if it is that
it pens it to the num string and at the
end it turns that back to an integer
sort of a weird thing but basically I've
used this before and some other programs
you can take any string you can parse
through the whole string grab all the
numbers of it and you want to make sure
they're numbers by using this just make
sure that whatever you're looking at is
a number and at the end you can turn
them back to an integer that way it's
like grabbed all the numbers out of a
string and called in an integer so
that's that's what that does since why
it looks that way so that one was a
little tricky to get right but I was
able to reuse some code I wrote
earlier time that worked quite quickly
it will copy pasta copy pasta code life
yeah thumbs up for cotton pasta code
life alright
so materials materials was really tricky
because sometimes in this JSON it was
just the word Noll like this not a
string and sometimes it was a string of
many different things there was numbers
commas all sorts of stuff in this one
and we didn't want to grab the word
material and make sure it was this we
also wanted to grab it if it had a beat
in the word Noll which looks a lot like
material in a way as far as regex is
concerned because it starts with a
lowercase and has only lowercase
characters same so this one that I
probably spent the most time on honestly
to get this right there this material
and as you can see it's rather large so
first it checks us with the word null I
couldn't find a better way of doing this
that's like alright let's just see if
the word know exists in the line if it
does it sets material as none returns
true it's like hey we got it it's not
it's a nun and otherwise if it gets
through all this and doesn't return true
it's not a null there's something there
so we start a new reg X pattern and this
took me forever to find a good version
of because there are also on occasion
parentheses in that in that material its
parentheses spaces all kinds of
different characters caps and I did an a
through L and through Z so basically as
long as it doesn't start with an M
because I didn't want to grab the word
material I kept having that problem but
if you see like a morsel food starts
with a lowercase almost all these start
with a lowercase if there is actually
something and regex would often grab the
word material so to correct that I just
said okay as long as it's not an M we'll
start with something that's on them and
that seemed to cut out material all the
time I don't think there were any
materials that started with the word M
if they if there were this wouldn't this
would fail
those cases but it seemed to go through
the entire list of spells without
failing so it looks like the materials
never starts actual material stuff I've
never started with an M so this ended up
working right there just cut out the M
on those and I got a lot of C outs here
too as I was building I just left them
in for now
so also we're looking in for things in
between quotations so a little escape
character a quotation escape character a
quotation and I did this just to see how
many matches there were just a little
for loop out putting that was that was
purely for debugging purposes don't need
those anymore but you know I'm gonna
leave and just maybe a debug more I
don't know so as long as it's not the
word material which it couldn't be
because so this is actually a kind of a
dummy case that will never matter that's
always false so we can go ahead and
correct that but what we're looking at
here is we don't want the quotations but
we had to encapsulate them I forget why
I guess I don't necessarily since I
already checked for the ordinal summary
was when I was building I decide it was
a good good idea and tried it and it
worked so basically what I did is okay I
grabbed everything including the
quotations because I made it a little
easier to regex the right thing in some
cases and I just stripped the quotes
with a substring of you know everything
but the beginning and end so that's how
I strip the quotes there I said okay
take the string temp make it equal to
whatever we her match was and then we're
gonna take temp and get a substring of
it that cuts off the beginning so it
starts at 1 instead of 0 so that skips
the first first quotation and length
minus 2 because length length doesn't
consider 0 like it's a string with 10
characters it's gonna say 10 but if you
iterate through it
because coding stuff is a zero through
nine so this says ten instead of nine
and that's why it's minus two because we
only want to go to one through eight for
example rather than zero through well
dot length let's say ten so if we just
let dot length in there would say ten
which would be off the string so it
would be like it would actually crash
the program so one of like the hardest
things to get used to in programming is
considering this off by one case it's a
I wish there was a better way to handle
it but you just kind of have to know it
that when you get a dot length of a
string it tells you the actual length
which looks nice it's like ten
characters that return ten but if you
iterate through it you don't you don't
go one to ten you go zero to nine so
that's why there's always these weird
things that will often say like negative
two when you would think it should say
negative one stuff like that so brant
aside all right so we stripped the
quotes and we set the material to that
with the strict quotes and return true
and we're done all right then we got a
thing to find range which actually ended
up being quite similar to some of the
other cases except there was
occasionally a dash in there so I had to
consider that case then you have to
escape in a dash escape a dash with
regex
the regex standard in case you're
totally lost and don't understand how
these work you probably need to google
it just you know open up a browser and
go regex c++ you'll find this little
reference tells you some stuff here I'm
only using I'm using search and I'm
using what else am i using the regex
course and smash is for holding results
and there's other stuff you can do here
too
I'm not really using it so this can be
helpful personally like this site better
there's a lot of tutorials on these this
geeks for geeks one seemed okay but
honestly I read through it and I was
like
didn't it it seemed like it could be
explained a little better so I didn't
actually find that that helpful if you
go regex I think it's vici you can find
the week of pd-1
and this tells you all about regular
expressions and this has a lot more info
about let's see here you'll find it
about what all the different stuff does
what all these little characters do and
example matches you just have to put it
into C++ format which yeah so those can
be helpful like yeah I'll just say that
I want to go into too too much I'll just
say I probably should have said this
earlier but like this R means this
starts the regex and this ends it so
it's like I'm gonna press the space here
just be clear so yeah this is this
pattern right here and doing this R
means it's like a once I mean forget the
right word but basically it's verbatim
it's like yeah it's it's an exact match
so you have you can do feeder you're
regex with less escaped characters but
some of them you still have to escape
like quotations still need an escape and
this is a special thing of any word
character and this - here it's escaped
and when things are in these little
brackets like this right here it's a
single character but I have a plus at
the end of it so it finds as many single
characters as possible Plus being room I
take one or more is that right yeah so
it finds one or more of these it just
keeps going to revise them but things
and brackets are for single character
finds
so I think that's enough about that if
you have more questions feel free to ask
in the comments or dig through that
documentation and maybe your question
will be answered there all right and so
on and so on and so on a special case
for ritual specialists case or school
when I upload this video the comp below
I will have a link this repo so you can
check it more carefully if you want but
I think I went through enough at this
point I'm just gonna do a run and we'll
call it a day so look at this make file
so I had already built up a lot of this
and I only needed to do kind of the rest
of it so I made a test - that was just
the rest of the spells I hadn't
completed and there were 50 of them and
I calculated that by you know just
counting them I think so it should find
50 spells if it gets them all so I'm
gonna do make test one our best - to run
it on this test - text it'll go ahead
and rebuild it since I made some changes
and parse through it shows me all my
output for all the C outside did for
testing and there it does a complete
found 50 spells and it put it on an alt
text dot txt so here they all are
starting with spike growth ending with
ozone the truth and it looks like it did
each one pretty well there and you can
kind of look through these real quick
and see ok classes paladin looks like
that somatic verbal material correctly
set this to none as intended rather than
some weird thing anything you just kind
of flipped through these real quick and
check there's a a couple classes listed
correctly same there we don't see any
rogue or fighter and these listed so
it's looking pretty good and I can do it
with every single spell on that list
make two bonds might take a moment you
can see it's going through every single
one 346 found puts them in this out text
and it starts with the acid splash now
boom there's every single one parsed
through in just a moment I cannot
believe it's been so many hours manually
doing this
before realizing that no I just use my
coding skills to parts through it but
hey sometimes you live and learn and as
you can see okay on these outputs
sometimes it's looking through just a
line that's just a bracket and it just
you know skips and does the same step
again looks through and you know it gets
the end of the file peer exit that wild
loop now puts it as his spells get
together all that stuff all right
well there you go there's a use case of
regex and c++ to save a lot of time
hopefully this will help somebody who's
struggling with regex
this is probably a little longer than I
intended but hopefully it'll it'll be
clear as clear as I intended you know
all right well if you if you like seeing
my stuff hear my voice you know
subscribe man welcome welcome to the
whatever our crews called I don't know
what our crews call only got 20 subs you
can make it 21 or more or millions
millions of subs we're going for
millions don't forget to give this a
thumbs up leave a comment I appreciate
every comment if I'm doing something
terribly wrong and backwards and could
save a lot of time or you can save
someone a lot of time that's awesome or
maybe you just want to say hey thanks
that's cool too I appreciate all you
guys and until next time keep code peace
out